who's the next black panther i can't
tell you
but
but i think what we do see is they're
all heroes
because they all have to overcome
a huge feat
which is the loss of someone incredibly
important and central in all their lives
and i think the movie really deals with
the fact that we we can all be heroes in
in a strange way
art really reflected life
with this
the characters in this movie aren't the
only ones that have suffered great loss
within the last several years great how
are you right so we're all coming
from this macro place of
survival
right and rebuilding who we are and what
it all means
and i think we're all going to get to
see that so we're all heroes in that
sense i think the entire thing is a
great honor you know
it was a really big feat for us to pick
up the baton
you know that he left us it was like
handing us the baton
and we have to shoulder this story you
know as a collective
that is about a lot of grief
and um
yeah every single day we dealt with that
in our own different ways you know
everybody had
depending on the scene depending on what
was going on
and he was one of those people that
his presence was quiet but expansive
so
you don't notice that he's
you don't notice how large of a presence
he filled until he's not there
and that's something that you know
that's just all throughout this process
so we're still all kind of recovering
and growing from it but it's something
special that's all i can tell